rats are one of the more
controversial animals that inhabit our
planet they get between walls shoe wires
spread the plague
not a great rap the word alone has
become a universal insult synonymous
with shameful traits like dishonesty and
cowardice and in esports it's also been
used to disparagingly describe
dubious yet highly effective strategies
i'll act like i'm selling him to make
you feel make him feel better
well that's it little does he know
there's another one i'm gonna buy last
minute
this is a true red move
it's actually a rap move but when it
comes to first person shooters
being called a rat
takes on a more literal meaning
rats hide in corners lurk in the shadows
sneak up behind their unsuspecting
victims and just about everyone hates
them that being said whether we want to
admit it or not
there's nothing inherently wrong with
playing like a rat it's not cheating
it's just
annoying as [ __ ] to deal with
no way you're sitting there still this
guy's playing where he just spawned
for a minute of all the operators laxing
is all the way in narnia with the
quality
and the wall of billiards oh my god he
gets it
relaxing oh you want to talk about rat
that is ridiculous where are these
players man holy this is such a campy
rat fest but rats are far more than just
a pain in the ass
they're psychological weapons
nuisances capable of creating paranoia
and a creeping sense of uncertainty
through their unpredictable positioning
and their mastery of timing why not do
it with some support though have another
player there and you know if he had
another player that player could
probably get to trade
oh my god get right in recent years
we've seen the rat inspired lurker role
become less prevalent in cs go thanks to
the game's growing emphasis on big brain
executes over sneaky cheesy individual
outplays but invalorant where there are
only so many lineups and post plants you
can pull off
things are a little different and thanks
to the game practically being a
shift-walking simulator some high-level
players are starting to realize the
merits of playing
well
like a rat okay what play they're going
to rotate off he heard the drone he
heard
what a rat steel playing super smart
but of all the sneaky [ __ ] disturbers
frequenting valorance servers
none have reached the lurking heights of
ayaz nats ahmachen the insanely talented
sentinel player for gambit esports who
has proven himself to be the game's one
true rodent king we thought gnats had
snuffed by mix well it turns out it was
the other way around that's now having
to clutch this one out no idea where
mixwell is in the snake fight not quite
clearing the angle he's about to run to
sight reloading and mix well
completely whips
three kills five rounds there seems to
be no way for g2 to get off the starting
point this is absolutely ridiculous that
nats guy is unreal
that guy is unreal so how exactly did
nats begin his journey to becoming
valeran's biggest pest why has he been
able to find such success with this
annoying play style and most importantly
is valerian gonna become infested with
more nuisances like him or is he just a
one-off problem look at this but i mean
get out of here
the rattiest player i've ever seen in my
life the fact that he could look two
kills why not yeah give give them all of
them how is he there how how is he there
i don't understand how does he manage to
do that
all right guys so before we pay tribute
to the one true rat king of valorant
please scurry your way on over to the
like button burrow into the subscribe
one and turn on notifications
just please don't slow walk onto a site
play with the team okay so if at this
point you are a valorant fan in any
capacity nats should pretty much be a
household name but there's more to the
man than just his penchant for clapping
the world of valoran's collective cheeks
like the fact that deep down he's
actually a lover not a fighter just ask
his stuffed panda i just bought two of
them one for me one for my girlfriend
and right now that's panda's name is the
my girlfriend's name and she always is
me it's nice to know that this tin man
does have a heart since the community
has been
somewhat preoccupied with his occasional
lack of
feelings oh he's smiling holy [ __ ]
people need to be worried he just
he showed real emotions oh my god oh my
god the robot bro how happy are you to
be you know not the first uh
non-european team but the first cis team
to be able to do it i don't know i don't
have any emotions about that
actually about that i don't have any
feelings but when this romantic robot
isn't making some of the best players in
the world look like bots on lan you can
regularly find him on stream blowing the
minds of his teammates
but as accomplished as nats might be
he's still not above bowing to the
demands of his fellow zoomers in chat
say sheesh
anyway that's his esports adventure
kicked off the way that any young head
clicker from the cis's would
with counter-strike he first started
playing the game competitively on
several amateur teams in kazan as early
as 2017 and it didn't take long for
people to notice just how good he was
now as much as nats enjoyed competing in
cs go his career wasn't progressing as
fast as he would have liked but after
heeding the advice of his brother and
making the switch to valorant things
really began to pick up actually i
didn't have a lot of
achievements in cs that's why i said
okay
my brother said more than me let's try
yourself in valorant and
with that thing
i'm
not gonna be that's right now in front
of you thanks to the obvious
similarities between valorent and cs go
it didn't take long for nats to find his
groove he started competing at smaller
regional events on a stack throughout
2020 and thanks to his obvious talent
was snapped up in september by gambit
esports now part of what caught gambit's
attention was nats's mechanical ability
and experience communicating with a team
but another major selling point was his
unique approach to playing the sentinel
role typically sentinel agents serve a
supportive purpose in a team they gather
info anchor a site and shut down
aggressive pushes but that's not quite
how nat saw it no on top of their base
functions he looked at agents like
cipher and viper and saw untapped
potential especially when it came to
using their kits to seize map control
and soon enough
that started to become his signature
wait wait wait wait
bench
wait wait wait
one enemy remaining
uh
one enemy remaining
thanks to his ability to navigate the
map like a spectre and catch his
opponents completely off guard
nats was outperforming and out fragging
even the standard spotlight hogging
duelists of valor of course the concept
of lurker isn't exactly new to valorant
or
tactical shooters as a whole and over
the years especially in counter-strike
we've seen just how impactful it can be
when exercised by a master lurking's not
so much about like getting flanks it's
it's about the pressure applied in
places
to create an opportunity
at their core lurkers
are the ultimate rats they're a nuisance
not just because they're sneaky as hell
and can create chaos on the server but
because they're capable of perpetuating
paranoia which
psychologically
can throw people off and
knowing that
nats used it to his advantage off the
back of the hunter's fury and well this
round is done there's 20 seconds for
gnats and well he might not look phased
i genuinely think he might be the
calmest man in the universe like i don't
think i've ever seen his face move oh he
blinked he blinked 10 seconds left i was
certain to get cnet vibes off it
over the course of 2021 while sentinels
had a stranglehold on the spotlight
gambit and their rat king quietly began
making their names known in the vct they
ended up just short of qualifying for
reykjavik against fnatic but bounced
back at the emea stage 3 playoffs
locking down their spot at masters
berlin gambit on the verge
of walking away in that first position
that first spot nats again just coming
alive enjoying himself just running
rampage through smb as russ as your last
man alive as gambit now moments away and
there it is gambit are the emea stage
three champions and my god do they
deserve it heading into berlin gambit
had developed a bit of a reputation for
being scrim gods teams knew that they
were talented and had potential but nats
and his teammates were determined to
prove that they were more than that so
they did
he's going to put a snake bite down as
the wall breaks he can hold the angle
right after no problem flash doesn't
even catch him they're like i don't
worry no one's holding close anymore
flash didn't see him oh yeah he's still
here max is tucked in the corner waiting
to take the kills fisker is going to go
into it oh no he's even trying to wall
back him okay that's an ambitious play
they're doing it
second player spraying it's a 4k already
for nats leaving just gnats he thought
he'd given his team a free pass in
towards the a site instead he sent them
to their death
we thought gnats had snuck by mix while
it turns out it was the other way around
nats now having to clutch this one out
no idea where mix well is in the snake
fight not quite clearing the angle he's
about to run to sight reloading and mix
well
completely whips that's
three kills five rounds there seems to
be no way for g2 to get off the starting
point this is absolutely ridiculous
i can't believe what we've just
witnessed get me out come here how is he
not look at his face look at that
shadows is screaming and nuts is like oh
that's another round for me yup it
starts with mixwell by the looks of
things defoe's holding it with an off
and that's gonna be the rifle dropped
look at this but i mean get out of here
nice that's the ruddiest player i've
ever seen in my life the fact that he
could look two kills why not yeah give
give him all of them he's sitting in
spawn tom
how no no but no no but how how how is
he there how how is he there i don't
understand how does he manage to do that
and oh he's gonna get a killer pixels
what is this man doing
that is one of the most ridiculous
things i've ever seen this guy
he's defining the word flank
behind them
it's
absolutely obscene
oh g2 my heart goes out you are playing
gamut's game at this point he's even
come on yeah he's come up behind for the
third kill he's coming behind for the
third kill how off the back of their
impressive run in the knockout stage of
the tournament gambit found themselves
in the grand finals against envy who had
decisively sent home north america's two
strongest rosters but even with the
raised stakes and a tough opponent in
front of him
nats in typical nats fashion
wasn't phased at all the timing naps he
does not know what he's up against crash
he's just got red guard this has to now
speed up the hit from that's he's got to
make his impression load one two three
the third doesn't need his shields is
right there now it all swings down to
finesse to the 1v3 he's got the time on
his side but the shots ain't landing you
can see defoe's
and somehow they work it out 12 on the
board for gambit
creeping forwards just ahead of nats but
on the back of the seekers we have
popped and that's we'll swing on the
second crashes will fall
in position to find their finesse
we're in a simulation it has to be
we're in already momentum isn't really
stopping because look what gambit are
doing they're just stacking up mad
trades as nats doubles down on the frags
there's the all coming in too so that's
quite interesting could be a different
dynamic one trade out yeah he's gonna
find the pick towards top of middle
there's nats though still back to the
side still being a problem they still
need more though for envy in this they
need a bit more damage shadows he's
living on borrowed time but yay now gets
challenged down shadows wins against fns
and mv4 like boys chronicle the man who
just destroyed them in the prior round
is just around this corner over the top
i mean oh my god
yeah he's made a meal of it it's all
going to pieces
in the final moments has just shone so
brightly they are blinded by the lights
gambin are the valerian masters
champions
the final hurdle
was gambit and they just couldn't make
it across and the man in the middle
there as well you've got to say it nats
an outstanding performer throughout
catching everyone's eye i think the rat
king had finally secured his crown and
in doing so he and gambit had finally
proven to the valorant world that they
were truly a force to be reckoned with i
don't even know they [ __ ] [ __ ] on us
i don't even care that nats guy is
unreal
that guy is unreal honestly people hit
me for this but like obviously like n a
this i know that but like gambit is an
insanely good team and i have a feeling
they're they're going to wipe the floor
like gimmick is strong that's scream
bucks but gambit is a really good team
like we're learning a lot we played a
lot of practice with them um
since we came here and uh we've learned
a lot more playing for some in like some
of these teams than like you know when
we're playing back in n a they have like
some really good reads it's insane since
really putting himself on the valorent
map in berlin
nats's star status has only continued to
rise and fans aren't just tuning in to
watch him [ __ ] on pro players on lan
they're also showing up to his stream by
the thousands to get to know him a
little better
at the end of the day it's a little
early to say whether nats is pioneering
an entirely new meta-invalorant
but what isn't
is that he's an insanely good player he
knows when to switch tempo he's
extremely clutch and his aim simply
cannot be doubted but more importantly
beyond his obvious skills
he's changing the way that even his
peers think about the game he's a great
player he's you know when i've watched
him play he's insane he
hits some crazy timing he's super
knowledgeable he's a very good anchor a
lot of bomb sites i mean you play cypher
and viper so he's very good at playing
alone and absorbing pressure in a way
that not many people can and it's really
interesting to know that he's very young
as well he's a very he's super young and
he's
you know he plays very cerebral he's
very smart which is not something you
expect out of somebody so young so i
think that's what what he has going for
him i'm still learning to uh to try and
play viper as good as he is it's good to
see ken with that character and um
definitely taking tips from him on that
if he wasn't on everyone's radar before
he sure as hell is now he's won berlin
and doesn't seem to be slowing down
anytime soon we'll just have to wait and
see if teams can find a solution
to their new rat problem
[Music]
did you see that
okay so the most famous lurker to ever
play in cs because he's the og is get
right get right was the [ __ ] true
like the godfather of lurking the whole
thing with get right is that he would
always lurk he would always flank enemy
teams knew he was doing it and they
would still die to it
has this [ __ ] line this clip where he
uses it all the time and he has this
line where he says
like a sneaky beaky like a get right
and it's like my favorite thing it's
like my favorite screen clip of all time